إذن أنت في واشنطن العاصمة الآن
أنت وعائلتك من
ليسوا تعرفهم في المملكة العربية السعودية يعيشون في أه
في المنفى في كندا بما في ذلك والدك
بما في ذلك أخوك ماذا
تفعل في واشنطن وهل يمكنك
إخبارنا قليلاً  حول ما لمح إليه والدك
أنه يحاول جعل هذه الإدارة
تقوم بإدارة بايدن للقيام بشيء
ما لمساعدة نفسه على مساعدتك جميعًا
وللاحتفاظ بإخوتك وأقاربك الآخرين
من السجن ، أخبرنا ما
هي خطتك في هذا الصدد ،
حسنًا.  من الصعب علي أن أغادر
تورنتو لأترك ولداي الصغيرين
هناك وكانا مرعوبين من أنني سأذهب
ولن أعود أبدًا ، لكنني جئت إلى هنا
لسبب وهو أن أدافع عن
إخوتي وأخوتي وزوجي
للتحدث إلى  الحكومة الأمريكية
أم وإه توعيةهم بما
يحدث أه
لإه للاتصال بالرئيس بايدن الذي تحمل هو نفسه
الكثير من الصدمات العائلية ويفهم كيف
تعني خسارة الأسرة والألم يعني
نطلب منه التدخل والمساعدة
نحفظ عائلتنا ولم شملها
مرة أخرى
منذ أن علمنا أننا نجري
مقابلة معك ،
كنا نتصل بالمسؤولين السعوديين
في كل من الولايات المتحدة وأماكن أخرى
لمحاولة الحصول على رد
، وللأسف لم نتلق أي رد
في وقت بثنا
ونحن  لست متأكدًا مما إذا كنا سنفعل ذلك ،
فسأقرأ ما قالوه
لزملائنا في 60 دقيقة بشأن
والدك ، لذلك قالت الحكومة السعودية إن سعد
الجابري مسؤول حكومي سابق فاقد للمصداقية
وله تاريخ طويل
من التلفيق وخلق الإلهاءات
لـ  يخفي الجرائم المالية التي
ارتكبها والتي تصل إلى مليارات
الدولارات لتوفير أسلوب حياة فخم
لنفسه ولأسرته ، ولم
ينكر جرائمه في الواقع ، فهو يشير إلى
أن السرقة كانت مقبولة في ذلك الوقت
ولكنها لم تكن مقبولة أو قانونية في
ذلك الوقت.  ليس الآن
كذلك ،
عيسى الموساني ، فهم مصممون على
أن هذا هو سبب
معرفتك أنه يطلق هذه المزاعم
ضد المملكة سبب
هروبه وهذا هو السبب.  قصة حقيقية
وسُئل خلال 60 دقيقة عن
ثروته ،
لذا أخبرني قليلاً عن
ذلك كيف تتفاعل مع هذا البيان السعودي
جيدًا ، وأنا أعلم أن والدي بريء من
كل ما يتهمونه به ، فأنا
ابنة فخورة و  ما أعرفه هو
أن الطريقة التي
يتبعونها بإشراك أفراد الأسرة في اختطافهم وتعذيبهم بالسجن
ليست الطريقة الصحيحة التي
يجب أن تتصرف بها الحكومات
وهذا ما أعرفه ،
فلماذا تعتقد أن كندا هي
الدولة التي منحتك المنفى ومنحتك
اللجوء هناك
أنت تعلم أن هناك دعاوى قضائية مبارزة كما
تعلم أن والدك رفع دعوى قضائية في
واشنطن زاعمًا أن فرقة الاغتيال
سافرت من السعودية إلى كندا
لمحاولة قتله بعد أيام فقط من مقتل جمال
خاشقجي وتقطيع أوصال زميلنا الذي
رفعت عليه الشركات السعودية المملوكة للدولة دعوى قضائية في كندا.  والدك يدعي أنك
تعلم أنه سرق ما يقرب من نصف مليون
دولار من ميزانية مكافحة الإرهاب
ونحن نفهم أن القاضي الكندي
قد قال اقتباس  إليك
دليل دامغ على الاحتيال وقد جمدوا
أصول والدك
ما يحدث في المجال القانوني
هنا كيف ترد على ذلك
جيدًا أن والدي نفى جميع الادعاءات
والدعوى القضائية لا تزال جارية حتى
نعرف متى ينتهي هذا
في  في النهاية ، سنعلم
أن نقول مرة أخرى ،
أعني أن الدعوى القضائية لا تزال عملية مستمرة ،
لست محاميًا
للتعليق على أن ما أعرفه هو أن والدي
نفى جميع المزاعم
في هذه الأثناء
، هل ستحصل على الحماية ، هل أنت
محمي
لم يكن لدي أي أمن خاص وأمن كندي
بسبب كل هذا ،
وهل تخشى
أن يصبح
والدك
أو أي منكم ضحايا ،
قال بشكل قاطع لمدة 60 دقيقة
أنك تعرف أنه يمكن أن يصبح
خاشقجي التالي الذي لن يهدأ أم بي إس حتى يتم
إسكاته  وأنه مستعد
ليوم واحد
من رصاصة القاتل أو أي شيء
يصل إليه ،
نعم نحن نعيش في خوف من أن ننظر دائمًا إلى
أكتافنا
ولا نشعر بالأمان ،
ولا أعرف كيف لا نشعر بالأمان
والناس يعيشون.  هذه هي
مطاردة أفراد الأسرة
وإرسال فرق الاغتيال وقتل الناس في
السفارات
والقنصليات ، أعني بالطبع أننا
لا نشعر بالأمان لأننا مستهدفون أنا
شخصياً تم إنزال أه
إلى ال  القنصلية السعودية وإسطنبول ،
حاولوا
تشجيعي على الذهاب إلى هناك وأنا
محظوظ لأنني لم أذهب وإلا
فلن يكون لأطفالي أم وأب ، لذا نعم
نشعر بعدم الأمان
وسنشعر بالأمان فقط  عندما
يتم منع mbs من القيام بما
يفعله ،
فأنت تعلم أن ما قلته للتو أمر مروع للغاية ،
ليس لدينا أي
طريقة مستقلة لإثبات أننا لا نعلم
أنك قد استدرجت إلى أي
تثبيت سعودي
ولكن
ما تقوله هو  تقشعر لها الأبدان وقد رأينا
ما حدث كما قلت لزميلنا
جمال خاشقجي